okay in this problem a horizontal
circular pipe is visible up to the point
where it travels through a wall the
engineer can't see the pipe on the other
side of the wall but she can read a
pressure sensor mounted over there
claiming that the fluid on the other
side of the wall is lower than on the
side she can see is the diameter of the
pipe on the other side of the wall
larger or smaller than the diameter of
the pipe on the visible side assume that
the total energy and head is conserved
between both sides of the pipe and that
there are no head
losses so what this problem wants us to
do is utilize Bern's equation and that's
the first thing we need to recognize
from what it's telling us so it calls
out total energy and head being
conserved and it know that the pipe is
horizontal and that a pressure reading
is
provided
so here's what we can do
first let's search out broli in our
civil reference manual and let's write
out this equation real fast so the first
thing would
be
Z1 Plus plus P1 over
gamma plus V2 /
2G
equals
[Music]
Z2
plus P2 over
gamma plus v^
2 2 s over
2G so in this case
this side of the broli equation
represents the visible pipe that we can
see here and this side
represents the invisible side on the
other side of the
wall so the problem is essentially
asking us if the area or diameter of the
pipe specifically but
um if the area on one side is bigger
than the other so there's a few things
we can do to simplify this out
immediately the problem recom notes that
the uh the pipe is
horizontal so we can eliminate
our our elevation head from broli
immediately that leaves us with the
pressure
head and the velocity head so we have P1
over gamma plus v p1^ 2/
2G = P2 over
gamma plus v2^ 2 over
2G now there's one more thing we can
tell from looking at this it's noted
that the fluid pressure on the far side
of the wall is lower than on the side
that the engineer can see so let's say
just for reference sake here
that
P2
equal 12 of
P1 that might make it easier to think
about for some
people
um so what we can tell
is
since P1 is greater
than
P2 if the total head's going to be
conserved which is mentioned
here
then v1^2 over
2G has to be less than v2^ 2 over
2G and to take this logic one step
further let's take
our Q which is going to be constant
through the
pipe equal A1 * V1
equal A2 *
V2 so if we know that V2 is going to
be
[Music]
greater than
B1 ostensibly A2 has to be less than A1
if we're going to have the same constant
flow rate through the entire pipe so
therefore the answer to this problem
would be that the diameter of the
obscured pipe is going to be
smaller than the diameter of the visible
pipe since A2 is going to be less than
A1 the diameter on the other side's
going to be less than the diameter on
the visible
side so that's all it takes to solve
this problem is an understanding of
broli um if you want we can also just
look at this by plugging in real numbers
if you're the kind of person who has
trouble thinking about this just in
terms of
terms so let's come up with some some
random numbers here we're going to take
this first equation again
and we're going to start applying terms
to it so we'll say that Z1 equal 1
ft
and P1 will be equal to
5T per second squared because don't
forget that a pressure is a force over
an
area so oops
pounds not
feet saying it out loud helped me catch
that
so the gamma in this case is the
specific weight of water which is going
to be
62.4 pound per cubic
foot and oh I made another mistake up
top I was thinking about velocity for
some reason so it's pound per foot
squared over pounds per foot cubed which
is how it's going to end up with a foot
unit at the end to match up with this
one and finally we'll say the velocity
is
also 5 ft per
second squared
over 2 *
32.2 fet per second squared which is our
gravity uh General note too if you don't
have this
term
memorized it's a good idea to do
it but
also
gamma is
given in
chapters 1 3
7 but yeah memorizing 62.4 PBS per cubic
foot will save you a lot of time and
hassle so that's going to be the
equation on one side and let's let's
move this down
and make this a little easier
to to see sorry that we're moving stuff
around okay
so we can also tell
that so this is our one side of the
terms over here this is going to be
Z1 plus
P1 over
gamma plus v1^2 over 2G
equal Z2 +
P2 over G
gamma plus v2^ 2/ 2G so let's make up
some terms for this side we agree that
this is a horizontal pipe so this is
going to be one foot as well the
pressure we set is the reading on this
side is less than the reading on the
other side let's just claim it's half we
don't know and it doesn't really matter
anything we solve out for on this side
is going to
be is going to work out the way we need
to at the end for the area and the
velocity over
62.4
pound cubic
foot and then the velocity is what we
need to solve for here so that's V2 over
2 time
32.2 me perss squared
so solving this
out
would You' be able to just run the
calculations for this
side and then subtract out this term and
this term multiply by 2 * 32 and do the
square root and if we do all that we
will see
that b V2
=
5.25 F per second and this is going to
be greater than V1 which we
said was 5 feet per second so from there
you could go back
to looking at
this so you could just come up at that
point with a arbit flow
value and divide by
the calculated
velocity on either one and that will
give you the respective areas for each
side of the pipe as
well so yeah um coming up with fake
terms is probably not the recommended
strategy fake real numbers to play plug
in and check on the test just because
it's going to take a lot more time so if
you can work through with just the
equation like we did up here that's
going to be your best bet and then using
your understanding of these equations
such as
berol
and the equation for
flow using those two will be a much more
efficient way to solve a problem like
this okay that's it